mourners line the streets in islamabad
as ambulances carrying the bodies of
eight members of the same family drive
past
friends of navid iqbal are in shock they
say the police officer and his family
were well liked members of the community
i still can't believe it even after i
heard about this tragic incident the
whole country is grieving along with the
family navid iqbal was a very nice
person
this is a calamitous day
fell to minus 8 degrees celsius
overnight on friday in the mountain town
of murray around 30 kilometers northeast
of islamabad
thousands of people had traveled to the
resort to see the unusually heavy snow
ignoring extreme weather warnings
some reportedly died of hypothermia
after being trapped in their vehicles
overnight witnesses say others were
crushed by falling trees
some tourists died in cars trees fell on
the cars and caused their deaths i'm
just back from the area the army is
doing rescue work but the highway police
and the army will have to spend another
day completing the rescue work the
traffic jams are bad
the military has been called in to help
rescue thousands of people who are still
stranded but bad weather is making their
job difficult
pakistan's interior minister arrived in
murray on saturday to see the rescue
operation for himself
he promised that everyone still stranded
would be rescued soon
all government rest houses have opened
on the instructions of the chief
minister of punjab
we are starting a helicopter service as
soon as the weather clears but still the
weather is bad
if some people are stranded in forests
we will rescue them
prime minister imran khan says he is
shocked and upset he's ordered an
inquiry and is promising to introduce
new regulations to prevent a tragedy
like this happening again
victoria gatenbee al jazeera